well the less anti-gun agenda has scored
a major victory in the aftermath of the
proclaim Florida mass shooting officials
in the Chicago suburb Deerfield have
banned the possession sale and
manufacture of assault-style weapons and
large capacity magazines residents have
until June 13th to give them up and if
they refuse they will face fines of up
to one thousand dollars per day will
other liberal stronghold soon try to
follow in Deerfield's path joining us
now with reaction and Stamper credit
strategists Joel Payne Joel we've been
hearing for weeks that the left doesn't
have an anti-gun agenda they don't have
an agenda of banning guns but yeah here
we are with Deerfield Illinois not just
banning quote assault rifles which
really is a loaded political term we're
talking about semi-automatic sporting
rifles here but a number of other
accessories that they deem as
military-style well I don't think this
is actually the left that's doing this
this is a locality that's coming
together to do something for the safety
of their community the same as another
community did very near Deerfield
village I believe it was Highland Park
that in 2013 and they actually survived
a couple of legal challenges that show
that this is something that the court
did not stand in the way of it follows
suit with what Florida did in the
aftermath of the parkland shooting these
are localities coming together because
the national government because our
national leaders have failed to act
meaningfully on gun control on ensuring
that we are protecting our citizens from
gun violence not everyone was on board
with this though the majority of people
who spoke at the meeting said they were
against this measure I want to play some
sound from a woman who was at the
meeting who was actually against banning
these types of firearms there's gonna be
lots of talk about Second Amendment
rights
but I'd be hard-pressed to find any
right that is completely unrestricted
sorry she was for for this measure but
my question is how does Illinois not
have a number of pieces of legislation
and regulations on the book already when
it comes to gun control welllook states
and localities have the right to act to
make sure that they are protecting their
citizens the same way if you go to
certain counties they may be dry
counties where you can't have alcohol at
certain times have to be a certain age
to drive at a certain time is to decide
this is what will keep their community
safe okay you conservatives usually like
this by the way constitutional rights
excuse me are is drinking alcohol and
driving a vehicle are those
constitutional rights
those aren't constitutional rights but
those are certainly things that that our
governments in our in our in our
cherished amendments we have
restrictions on we have restrictions on
not to prevent us from being able to
enjoy them fully but to be able to enjoy
them responsibly well so ok and I think
it's very inconsistent ideologically for
conservatives to say that now they have
a problem with local governments and
localities coming together to protect
their conservatives don't believe in
taking out certain pieces of the Bill of
Rights depending on what place you live
in I would hope that the entire Bill of
Rights would apply that way but my
question for you based on the fact that
this ban did pass how are they going to
enforce this they say they're going to
charge people $1,000 a day if they don't
turn these firearms over by June 13th
are they then going to go search
people's homes unlawfully are they gonna
go get a warrant to decide whose home
they get to search and seize their
weapons how are you actually going to
enforce something like this why would
you assume they would do anything
unlawfully how do you how do you enforce
any other law or regulation or no I'm
honestly asking are you gonna go
door-to-door to people's homes and
confiscate their firearms how do you
enforce a law like this well I don't
live there but I imagine it's the same
way logins jaywalking I assume that
people if their car
it's the same exact thing no seriously I
mean the left talks all about how they
don't want to confiscate firearms they
passed legislation like this which what
we did the same thing they did not do
the same thing okay but answer my
question how do you enforce a law like
this without actually violating a number
of the other rights we have in the
Constitution like right to you know non
improper search and seizure how are they
going to enforce this law and how would
they do it across the country I'm not
quite sure how to answer your question
how to enforce a law I mean you have
force a lot of the way you do anything
you work with your local officials to
make sure that they are aware of what
the regulations are and you tape steps
to make sure the citizens are aware of
that
and if people run afoul of it you hold
them accountable for how do you enforce
any well this is exactly why gun owners
don't want a national registry because
by the way not just not it was upheld by
the seventh rat attack we gotta go and
also the